that's a way to be made to feel old
early in the morning Thank You Monica I
welcome you all on behalf of the
columbia alumni association and the 44
other members of the board of the CAA
representing at this juncture all but
one school in the university and they
are reorganizing their alumni leadership
and as soon as that is finished we will
identify a representative it's really a
pleasure to see you all today and I'm
not going to take very much time here I
have a little bit of business to do for
the business portion of the meeting but
this has really been an extraordinary
year represented best perhaps by the
opening of the new alumni center over on
113 'the street just east of riverside
drive virtually on campus and if you
haven't seen it yet I assume it's open
today yes and this is a this is a good
place to stop but maybe more importantly
since there are many other things to do
today and places to be it's a wonderful
place to go when you visit campus and
you have some time that may hang heavy
between meetings or while you're waiting
for someone to go use a computer read
the paper sit relax it also is the new
home of the university's alumni and
development staff and the leadership of
the college's alumni and development
staff a very important all most pivotal
integration of those two efforts on a
university-wide basis so this I think
represents a real commitment on the part
of the trustees and the administration
to provide the resources and in a
first-class way for the Alumni to return
to campus but it also represents I think
they're recognition of the priority of
the Alumni community because space on
this campus is extraordinarily scarce
with many competing demands for and very
high priority demands for use and when
the old school of social work became
empty as it relocated to its beautiful
new home any number of worthwhile
programs could have been put in that
building and alumni affairs was the
designated you so I think that's a
tremendous affirmation of the importance
of alumni a recognition of CAA and the
contributions made by people in this
room and so many others we have a piece
of business to do today the bylaws of
the CAA provide for the mechanisms by
which the board and other leaders are
identified and voted into office we have
by both a proxy mechanism and the
proxies are held by Donna McPhee and by
Monica given by those members of the
assembly who could not be here today
either for Geographic reasons or because
of other conflicts and those members of
the assembly who are eligible to vote
when the time comes and Monica will
conduct that part of the proceedings
there's a little green sticker in your
badge so when the time comes to raise
your hand pro or con if you have a green
sticker please do so if you do not have
a green sticker please refrain unless
you're prepared to vote yes you have at
your places the slate Brian Chris Berg
who is the vice chair of the CAA and
this year's chair of the nominating
committee was extraordinarily thorough
in identifying each aspect of the bylaw
categories that need to be satisfied
with respect to the composition of the
board I think it's all clear I'm
certainly
out to stand for reelection along with
several of my colleagues and i will turn
now the voting since I neither hold the
proxies and I am being voted upon I
don't think it's quite proper for me to
conduct the election and therefore I
will turn this back over to Monica and I
look forward to seeing you all later
today thank you